let's go to this story we got news uh
aaron j danielson died from gunshot
wound to the chest medical examiner says
i mean we all pretty much knew it
there's a few things that i really want
to talk about here
and i want to get into that uh there's a
tweet prior where they're trying to
liken what's going on to
nazi germany blaming trump supporters
for this this is crazy
they're posting fake videos from a
they're real they're posting videos from
someone else
defending that crazy guy in portland who
slashed three people
and they're claiming it was him and it's
not yeah and it's a it's a top comment
on the reddit post
they're saying that this guy was
defending that murderer dude
it's not true they're just lying that's
what that's crazy to me
and that's that's that's part of what i
was saying about how they like don't
google search things
they don't care and after them i have to
i just at a certain point
either we fire all these fake
journalists or we just accept they're
doing it on purpose
that's the only thing i can assume
because every time i see something like
that
all it takes is 15 seconds of google
searching
and the right you know search term and i
can come up with what i need
this is the funniest thing about like my
job is that i i get
hit by people who are like you know
thank you for like doing the work and
fact checking
i see reviews where they're like you
know tim always makes sure he has proper
sources i'm like it's true i do
and it's not hard it's possible yeah
i mean to be fair i think i think it is
fair to say
i do know where to go to find breaking
stories
right i do have a better assessment of
like what's true and i do uh
you know a lot of people don't like this
they claim i don't do journalism when
i'm literally verifying videos and fact
checking and finding the sources for
photos and videos
and i won't report on stories if you
know the sources are questionable
so it's true but it's amazing to me that
often like fact checking a story
requires like a google search i find a
twitter video
i find a corroborating tweet and then i
see a story in the new york times and
their source is law enforcement i'm like
looks good to me
yeah but then these other journalists
are just like well my grandma said that
this guy was a nazi
you know it's because they're working
backwards i'm fairly convinced at this
point that they are starting
from their conclusion and they're
working back and it doesn't matter what
gets in the way
they're going to say whatever needs to
be said to get to their credit
that's the craziest thing to me at a
certain point
they've they've come on man the american
people
if you want to pull the george carlin
thing when he said imagine how stupid
the average person is
now realize half of them you know half
of them are stupider than that yep
yeah it's funny george carlin was a
legend love that guy
and right right i get the point it's
true
however people aren't that stupid like
joe for joe biden to come out and be
like
donald trump joe biden literally said
your supporters coming out
and like intimidating threatening people
and i'm like do
do you think that all right listen
maybe the bottom 10 of of intelligence
are sitting there going like whoa those
guys wearing all black and screaming
black lives matter were white
nationalist trump supporters
that's crazy but come on that's gotta be
like
that's like forced gump wasn't even that
dumb you know what i mean those people
who are saying that those people who are
agreeing with that
are also working backwards they have a
conclusion the conclusion is orange mad
bad
whatever supports this i know i know i
get it but like
how do you have three months of footage
of people screaming black lives matter
and then joe biden goes listen those
guys
actually trump supporters and they just
go like oh
now that's right they were trump
supporters
maybe we maybe we esteem politicians too
highly
because i can't imagine someone else
saying that and getting away with it
i guess maybe maybe he's counting on
people who don't pay attention and they
just see the headlines definitely low
information
well so here's the first thing i want to
mention right um if you if you watched
my earlier segments then you know a
little bit about this but uh the guy who
was with
aaron danielson his name they called him
jay i guess his middle initial
said that they were walking the other
direction when someone yelled
we got them right here we got a couple
right here pull it out
here yeah they turn around bang bang
so it seems like these guys we now know
based on the witness it was the far left
as two yelled we got a couple right here
yep pull it out it wasn't them and this
guy aaron danielson turned around and it
does look like in this
like this really crappy grainy video
that he fires mace or whatever the left
is trying to claim that was self-defense
but based on the witness statement for
now it's the only statement we have
they turned around and saw a guy raising
a gun to him and so he
went for his mace right and it's like
man maybe you see someone raising the
weapon but
you don't know what to do it's a you
have a quarter of a second to decide
yeah what do you say and so he raised
the mace and then took two to the chest
so this guy was targeted based on the
witness statement i'll tell you what
the people who are trying to argue that
the far left this guy was defending
himself from mace
it's like you're going to be
hard-pressed to convince based on that
video
that you saw someone drawing mace and
therefore you decided to end their life
you could you could try and argue that i
couldn't tell what it was i saw him
raising something at me so i defended
myself
but it was almost the exact same time
and they approached him yelling we got a
couple right here yeah how do you
explain the audio
and then he fled as fast as he could so
apparently
this is crazy too um i guess his his
sister
is the one who uh turned him in we got
this from the daily mail portland
antifa protester who is under
investigation for shooting of patriot
prayer trump supporter
uh after being turned over to police by
his own sister
so apparently he was reported to police
by a sister who recognized him in photos
and videos from saturday night
this was not like listen the trump
supporters have a right to drive their
cars around and
and say silly things i that that's just
a fact of course
and so this is where it gets really you
know uh really frustrating in terms of
the national narrative
from the left they're like i saw a
journalism professor her her name is
emily bell i know i
you know i think she's a nice person but
she tweeted you know i had to call a
family member
scared because you know fake militias
are invading our towns i never thought i
would see something like this
and then a bunch of other journalists
are like oh i'm so scared i hope you're
safe
and i'm just my response was yeah i feel
the same way you know
i had to deal with that uh several times
when the riots were happening in chicago
with my family you know so the police
definitely need to shut this down
but where where where is this where's
the outrage over the fact that for
months these cities have been under
siege
were you not concerned about your family
member when the far left was burning
down buildings
yeah it's it's it's portland there's
been riots going on in residential
neighborhoods for months they physically
attacked him in her house
you didn't think to call your family
member and be concerned then maybe they
think that they'll be left
because they're special because they
agree with their points of view like if
you paint the right things on your wall
you'll be left alone
i gotta i just gotta say it i think
journalists are really dumb people
uh it's also possible yeah i do so and
the reason i think this is
early on in the in the industry
i'm talking like a long long time ago
and i guess it's it's it journalism has
been around for a really long time
you needed to you needed to know a lot
to
understand the world and create
compelling information i think one of
the reasons that
like this show does well and you know i
think one of the reasons probably a lot
of people watch is because i do a lot of
research all the time right
and so i'm very quick to be able to cite
or reference certain things
and it allows me to make better
predictions
because i've seen a bunch of different
things and i can see a lot of the
variables
today it's it's it's super easy you
don't want these news organizations
don't want to pay a lot of money
so they hire some college kid for dirt
the kid has no skills and they're like
we don't care
just write negative things about trump
and we're golden actually ryan long i
was just thinking of that
so uh ryan long the comedian put out a
new segment it was today right yeah
oh man it was so good it's called what
is it it's like um um a new news
trump leads when yeah trump's what news
is gonna do when trump leaves
and it's a bunch of people sitting
around all talking about their
anti-trump articles if he wins
but then it turns out he loses and joe
biden wins and they're all cheering
and then it's like one month later and
they're all sweaty like i need something
what do we have i got nine shares on
this article about the vice president
being a nice lady she looks good today
the press conference went smoothly
and then uh someone's like i got an
article about trump and he's like no
trump's lost he's just a guy now no one
cares
and then he gets a text message saying
like you know they're shutting down your
office and he just wanders off
but it really is true so what happens
when you get journalists who don't know
how to do research
and who don't care to do research that's
the big issue they're not passionate
about their jobs
they're lazy and they just want to get
to the day it it listen
when you've got an office full of people
like all these lefty journalists who are
socialists or whatever
they all tend to be supporting this
stuff they don't want to work right the
last thing they want to do
they're like i shouldn't have to work
they're like we should have a four day
work week rent is fast
dude i work all day every day not
because i'm doing it because like it's
you know what man i don't know what they
really want to do with their lives
do they want to like just sit around and
have team crumpets or something probably
so this is something that i saw a little
bit when i was working in nursing too
there were people who were in the field
that i was like
you shouldn't be doing this you should
not be here you should find a different
job
why what were they doing they were unset
they were insensitive they were
impatient they were really sometimes
dishonest and i was like
nah you shouldn't be doing this you
should not be in this field at all i
feel like all these lazy journalists
like if you don't want to do research
and if you're not interested in
historical stuff that happened that's
not the right field for you find
something else
you you know what they want it's a quick
path actually
let me start over this is what i've been
talking about politicians
they're not good enough at anything to
become noteworthy so they're like
if i can just tell people whatever it is
they want to hear and i get elected
then i'll have my name in the history
books and i will have yeah
same thing with journalists yeah a lot
of these people are narcissists who are
like
everyone should know my opinion and i
shouldn't have to do any work for it
blue check syndrome
blue check syndrome yeah i've seen a lot
of uh blue checks
you know they're famous no no i was
gonna say like the things they do the
unethical things they do desperate for
followers and retweets and everything
and i'm just like i roll my eyes i'm
like
yeah really i've had people hit me up
asking like how do you get more
followers and i was like i don't know
do good work dude i was like you know
what i do i go on twitter and i just
like
when i say i just tweet i just i don't
even know think about
it i rarely re uh respond to people
relative to what i post
and i just will like see an article and
i'll be hit and i'll just like tweet it
out
and that's it this is interesting so
what they what a lot of these
journalists end up doing is like
replying to people
because they're like you know do the
reply guy thing i don't like the idea of
depending on someone else for your
like engagement why would you not go out
and talk to people on your own this
makes sense to me they're not good
enough at anything to
to actually earn followers i'm starting
to agree and i don't think they really
have enough original
thought to really be famous on twitter
on their own look at these reply guys
who will like whenever trump tweets they
respond immediately but look at their
their
their soul tweets like go to their
twitter account and look at their just
regular tweets and there's no engagement
they're so they're they're boring like
they don't have they really don't have
original thoughts that they tweet out
all they do is reply
no i mean you know even what i mean is
they might tweet something at trump like
you stink in your orange
a million retweets but then they'll
tweet something like i like a grilled
cheese sandwich and it gets 10. yeah
showing whatever it is they're doing
they're getting little to no engagement
but i'll tell you what man some people
are making insane amounts of money like
six figures
no joke on twitter yeah from selling
stuff
and doing it to my patreon and here's my
paypal yeah
that's the that's the creepy game of
twitter peop you know
people need to realize this because i've
been taught i've been looking at some of
these activist threads
and it's you'll see it they'll post
something like can you believe our
president is orange
why is our president orange isn't that
dumb and it's got a million retweets the
next tweet is
donate to my paypal to support me if
they get
100 million impressions on that and they
got that link
and they i mean what they could probably
get a couple grand
yeah i i doubt they're actually getting
anything near that but if they get
50 bucks every time they do it they're
incentivized to produce the most
psychotic
garbage imaginable i don't like
monetizing that yeah i know well they
want them retweets
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you